[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tera Eric a long time my dear close
personal friend we've been watching
movies for a minute now huh say your
name Andrew Flash Gordon oo that was
good I like that we're going to watch
The
Exorcist I'm actually uh scared cuz he
built it up telling a story about his
dad so my dad saw this in 1973 the year
it came out and he told me that the
theater was packed full of people and
when he went to see it by the end
credits there were only two people
remaining plus himself so it'd be three
and so I'm like great yeah that's
terrifying I'm terrified so you know
just leave a like leave a comment tell
us um how great we look when we get
spooked out and also do not forget to
ring the
bell ring the bell to subscribe also if
you are not a super sexy reject you
should get on board and you get on board
by going to patreon.com and signing up
the Royal Rejects and pledging some MOA
to support us all also don't forget that
Greg and John cover several shows over
there exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
that was like my rap it could have been
a lot better but I thought that was
great it was pretty good right you guys
are like four stars four out of five I
totally absolutely agree uh here's my
scream in preparation are you ready I'm
ready okay I'm ready to lose some
Do It
Go the music oh my
goodness it's like very religious type
of music I am already
scared
scared of what you're going to
find whoa all
right don't reach in there please I
wonder if he's like where are the skulls
at what are we doing with these coins
and plates here oh God is that a baby
skull what is it it looks like a
heart
[Music]
is he naturally like that or because of
all the stuff he's been touching I feel
like he found that baby skull and
freaked
out yeah something's wrong with him I
mean that artifact that he found must
have meant something big and we don't
know what it is
yet
oh gosh it's the sound
man jump scare number one out of the
[Music]
way
who started as friends we are now
Brothers this actor is doing a good job
of just making me feel easy watching him
though yeah like that something is
really wrong especially when they said
evil against evil like when he was
holding that artifact it's sort of like
the evil is brewing within him and he
must go take care of
it God this is so Eerie yeah it's the
sound is
like
yeah
oh what the
fudge oh my
goodness
what oh my God the sound of this is
killing me oh my God that's so spooky
yeah is that a script yeah looks like
it can tell this is going to be a
pattern of we're going to be scared by
noises yeah
right what the heck is that it's is it a
dog or what's that noise there's
probably like a crow in the
Attic NOP just a window open I mean
again it's super hurly in the film but
all the noises that they're making are
just
creepy the dog thing freaked me out yeah
even when they were hitting the iron
with the coal yeah
everything oh Carl we've got rats in the
atct you better get some
traps oh oh okay on set
cool I like how it's it says Warner
Brothers on there and Warner Brothers
made the film it's very meta yeah C you
you can't accomplish anything by
shutting okay cut
that's actors's favorite words cut
that's a
w but then I get post gig depression and
I just want to go back to set I think
walk home tonight M okay you take that
drop by my
house I've definitely heard this music
in the past well it's also it's also a
Halloween I was going to say yeah that
and also I've been to haunted houses and
Ma
exist I've heard this music there okay
it's iconic I know what everyone's
thinking for someone who does get scared
so easily why do I like haunted
houses talk to them all I don't know
anyone can't we get a horse well now
we're in
[Music]
Washington back oh they have such a cute
relationship mom I could take you
somewhere where you'd be safe you
wouldn't be alone this is my house and
I'm not going no place stubborn but I
get where she's coming
from a nice son that's such an old
school $10 bill he's a good boy yeah
he's a nice son he's just trying to look
out for her too when he was making that
suggestion oh yeah for sure sure hey
where' this come
from you been playing with it yep you
know how I have never played with a
Ouija board oh yeah well let's
both Captain howdy said no Captain howdy
do you think my mom's pretty Captain
howdy that isn't very nice well maybe
he's
sleeping hey you know we never finished
seeing all the sits in Washington and
tomorrow night I'll take you to a movie
okay oh I love you
a really doing a good job making you
feel the history between these two yeah
you can bring Mr Dennings if you like
cuz BR and I are just friends okay
really
okay the SE the sound change yeah Andrew
already needs a new pair of underwear
it's my mother Tom I need reassignment
Tom I went out of this job it's wrong
it's it's no good I need out I'm
unfit I think I've lost my faith
tomoh that's not a good thing as a
priest NP Jesus Christ can you believe
this he doesn't even call his daughter
on her birthday for Christ's sake maybe
the circuit is busy oh circuit's my ass
oh I thought the dad had perished I
thought that too cuz she was wearing her
wedding ring too and the way they were
talking I thought he was gone what are
you doing here my bed was
shaking I can't get to
sleep okay yeah I don't think it's
rats what's that sound I don't like it
rats usually just sound like crawling
sounds that's yeah it sounds like a
monster about to
Roar my God God girl get a flashlight
what are we doing here you have a lot of
people that work for you just get one of
them to do get up
[Applause]
there okay the tension
[Music]
suspense what the uh Jesus Christ Carl
don't do that no rats no rats thanks a
lot that's
terrific I still would want to know what
the heck that sound was yeah I'd be like
does anybody else hear
this
whoa that's up
yeah
like all of this is super
intense oh what girl what why
no can you feel
this I don't feel
anything okay what happened to herang
they took her blood now she's a
different person what's going on here
this tells your temperature and the red
light goes on that's your
temperature that's
old pent up with anger oh my God what is
going on I mean she mentioned her bed
was shaking when she was in it oh right
and then she saw that the image in her
head yeah Rin I think that's the answer
have you ever known your daughter to
swear no never well she let loose quite
a string while I was examining her visit
me well I find that hard to believe
what'd she say I wanted to hear
it she advised me to keep my fingers
away from her
God
you don't think a
psychiatrist uh I do the edem affected
her brain you understand him she don't
let no doctor come near her she was all
the time screaming even talking to the
radio you should have called me the
minute it happened oh boy Mama it's Demi
mama oh no poor poor thing why you did
this
why could you put us someplace else like
what Private Hospital who got the money
for that de
you that was a really quick cut scene
boxing I get what they were trying to
established like hey I'm letting out
some like that was like a 5c yeah yeah
totally Mike what goes on there I mean
who's the priest I keep seeing there
Damen Carris he's our our psychiatric
counselor he had a pretty rough knock
last night poor guy his mother passed
away oh no my God that's so
sad you
see oh she is not cuz she's
demented he plays drunk pretty well I
like that guy I'm a method actor I would
actually get drunk so I could just
naturally do
[Music]
it oh girl she's like I can't sleep shut
up you're going to die
there what is happening holy to Molly
honey the bathroom's over there honey
what's the matter I'm sorry she's been
sick she didn't know what she was say
rlin just kicked in
is it coming out Willie I think so
good oh God poor
thing oh our bed is shaking okay at
least the mom got to see it and knows
she's not like she's not full of crap
now okay from this point forward she's
sleeping in my or we're leaving the
house first of all right or or she'll
just have to sleep with mom cuz Mom bed
has not shaken yet they're going to have
to see that priest
ASAP oh no that was the same image she
saw right with the possession
yeah I don't want it
bastard it's rare but it does cause
bizarre hallucinations shaking of the
bed that's doubtless due to muscular
spasms oh no no no that was no spasm
there do the whole bed was thumping and
Rising off the floor and shaking the
whole thing with me on it it's her brain
no no doctor it's just like at this
point what are you supposed to I don't
know you're going to feel something a
little bit cold and
wet what are they doing I'm assuming a
cat scin but I don't know are they doing
the temperor lobe thing oh
boy looks
painful oh boy that looks even more
painful you're going to feel some
pressure here now
don't I mean knock her out what are we
doing here
oh my
God no thank
you yeah I don't want to see that either
okay I just have to pretend it's fine
it's a movie it's a movie I like blood
when it's like you have to kill someone
and it's revenge or it's like a zombie
but this ah H
up oh my God
oh let me guess her frontal Lo is fine
there's nothing there no vascular
displacement at all Chris no's on the
phone she says it's
[Music]
[Applause]
urg something oh my God please mother oh
make it stop he's holy
junk all
right the is
mine me
whoa stay away from
me oh my
God
okay this is
intense Dr Tanny says the x-rays are
negative in other words normal ah
there's nothing more these guys can do I
think it's time we started looking for a
psychiatrist I think she suggested that
a while back to you sir uh pretty sure
she's been saying we should get one and
you guys have been like let's do some
more
testing oh my God what it uh NOP yeah
I'm not digging the flickering light uh
no girl go get your
flashlight oh no
what it's like freezing in there oh yeah
wow breath is showing it's like this
girl's got to be like frozen over what's
Burke got to do when I went to get the
thorine I had him stay with her and
haven't
heard huh what Brook's dead oh no what
he fell down from the top of the steps
right outside by the time he hit M
Street he broke his
neck oh my God oh
no oh
no uh-uh I would I would pick her up and
drag her straight to church and say
listen even if I'm not a Believer take
her oh my God are you comfortable Reagan
yes how old are you she's an incredible
actress mhm is there someone inside you
sometimes if he talks to me I think
he'll leave you do you want him to leave
you yes
oh my God this poor girl is traumatized
if you are there you two are hypnotized
and must answer all my questions let's
say this in a hypnotist who are
[Music]
you
whoa oh my goodness that's a crazy shot
oh William F Kinder homicide perk
Denning good father was found at the
bottom of those steps leading to m
street with his head turned completely
around
yeah yeah okay you're the psychiatrist
you know who was sick at the time who
wasn't I don't know anyone who fits that
description but a psychiatrist was put
in jail for not telling the police what
he knew about a
patient thing I could always tell the
judge it was a matter of confession H
he's good it looks like the type of
disorder that's rarely ever seen anymore
except in primitive color
we call it oh man with those scratches
now you ever heard of exorcism it uh has
worked the victim's belief in possession
belief in the power of exorcism can make
it disappear at this point I'd be
willing to try anything oh yeah also
where are the
[Music]
psychiatrists when they said uh Burke
had passed away for some reason I
thought they were talking about that guy
that yeah I didn't realize they were
talking about the director from her mood
the guy who was drunk at the party right
I guess I think his name she wouldn't be
I don't think she would be dating him
right the helper cuz when the daughter
asked earlier
but oh my God I would padlock her door
just to be like don't come after me in
the night
sweetheart
oh my God is it that Stone from the
beginning yeah did you put it there of
course I didn't I didn't put
it excuse me mam what she really brings
a lot of intensity to this role mhm
she's all wound up it isn't likely he
would fall from a window at the deceased
was killed and then pushed from your
daughter's window
H
oh those look similar to the at the
beginning uh I'll come back when she's
feeling
better I'm actually sure the mom would
like that because that means she got
better so it's like fine
right that's a lot of new
crazy information on top of what already
is going
on
[Music]
you oh my God
Jesus
no no no no
oh duh
what oh boy oh my
[Music]
God you
did okay let's get this guy to help
please oh my God need an exorcism oh my
God it just so happens that somebody
very close to
is is probably
possessed and needs an exorcist it's my
little
girl you could do it yourself no I
couldn't I need Church approval and
that's rarely
given I would say just come see her yeah
there we go you know he felt powerless
to help his mother maybe this could be a
good yeah way for him to yeah like an
arc for him kind of
thing
oh my
God hello Reagan what oh my God the
makeup is amazing though what I'm Damien
Caris and I'm the devil where's Reagan
in here with us wow show me a Reagan and
I'll loosen one of the straps when
you're helping all Al the boy father
your mother's in here with his cat
oh oh that is
that is low that is so low then you must
know my mother's maiden
name what is
it
no
[Music]
jeez why does the Slime have to match
your eyes so precisely I
can't that f it would scare the crap out
of me so much wonder if he's willing to
perform an exorcism now well he better
be look I'm only against the possibility
of doing your daughter more harm than
good nothing you could do could make it
any worse seriously yeah it's already
really bad buddy you ask me what I think
is best for your daughter 6 months under
observation in the best hospital you can
find did you know my mother died
recently yes I did I'm very sorry
no is Reagan aware of it not at all why'
you ask cuz she knew also like
schizophrenics don't change their voice
that much I was going to say her this
girl is like like yeah she's a little
girl and her voice is like extra deep
yeah also her eyes changed to bright
green yeah the vomit was bright green
look like fresh avocados I mean it's all
sorts of complicated I mean I I hope you
can hear me can you hear me okay well uh
let me see
it's a cool shot yeah how it's I was I
was noticing that too as you said it
what an excellent day for exorcism you'd
like that intensely but wouldn't that
drive you out of Reagan the makeup is
insane yeah I'm curious what happens
when you do that like does it just come
out or does it go back down how long are
you planning to stay in Ran until she
rots and lies stinking in the
Earth what's that holy water holy
water it
burns who are
you what
the
nering I don't think I'd ever be able to
sleep again if I experienced that no way
no
way want a drink
please can I have like 10 drinks I told
Reagan that was holy water I sprinkled
it on her and she reacted very violently
It's tap water and that doesn't help
support a case for possession I'm like
also didn't he see her head turn all the
way around that I'm like and you don't
think she he's like come on
[Music]
now ah
what is
that oh is that like
writing oh it says help me oh it's from
Reagan inside got it oh poor thing oh
that music it's terrible you would want
to do the exorcism yourself
yes I doubt there's any danger in just
having him assist what about the
Exorcist have you any ideas maybe the
guy from the beginning about Lancaster
marin oh ocean he was over in Iraq I
think I read that he was working on a
bingo you got it he's had experience I
didn't know that the exorcism supposedly
lasted months heard it damn near killed
him what did they say at the beginning
evil against evil
yeah feel like I've seen this image
somewhere yeah it's spooky him getting
out of the cab been come in out like I
know I've seen this image somewhere yeah
okay this right that looks like a poster
right yeah I've seen this before it's
cool shot yeah is Father Carris here yes
Father father Caris I was wondering when
we were going to get packed from the
beginning oh God the demon is a liar he
will like to confuse us the attack is
psychological Damian so don't listen
remember that oh goodness so far I'd say
there seemed to be three she's convinced
that there's only one he's experienced
in
this wow really hope the makeup team won
in Academy Award or something cuz this
is amazing they did
yeah our father in
Heaven oh
God let the enemy have no power over I'm
the son of iniquity be to harm your
mother's and Hell
faithless holy Lord Almighty
father the bed to crush that roaring
lion hasten to our call for help God
forever and ever amen oh Lord hear my
prayer what the oh my God and let my cry
come unto thee Almighty
lord gave to your Holy Apostles the
power to underfoot serpents and
scorpions
[Music]
whoa oh my God
no no I can't oh my
God okay just pretend like it's gak oh
god
father
my goodness this is incredible
concentration oh my God this is like so
much you out unclean Spirit show up your
ass in the name of Jesus
Christ who in the name of the father and
of the son by this sign of the Holy
Cross of our Lord Jesus
Christ with the father and the Holy
Spirit no it's coming all the way
around you K shut up you sh command you
by the judge of the oh no this
is It's the power
holy dude the effects are amazing in
this yeah the power of Christ compels
you the power of Christ compels
you the power of Christ compels you God
the Father commands
you the blood of the martys commands
you oh
no oh
no
what let's rest before we start
wow really struck in but the mother
comment bro I would get out of that room
right
now oh his pills oh right from the
beginning
yeah he's like I need to take the whole
damn lot I mean he's this is a
lot that's messed
up de you do this to me oh
no her heart she going to
Coma you're not my mother don't listen
why
me
Our
Father who out in heaven hellow be thy
name is it
over is she going to
die
no is it her father calling or the
detective yeah the
detective
oh goodness gracious oh no what happened
what and what is she doing under the
corner of the bed no ah
no oh no you better grab that holy water
real
quickness
ah
damn you got to step your game up now
you son of a
take me this dude's a boxer too take
[Applause]
me
me what
[Music]
[Applause]
what oh my goodness this is how they all
die
oh oh I did not see that coming at
all oh my God I feel like it's still in
the room cuz it went in him and then he
looked normal and he jumped out the
window oh
god oh
boy I really was not expecting that at
all mean either do you want to make a
confession
oh he's still alive oh he's oh are you
sorry for having a God all the s of your
past
life I think he's still
possessed yeah let's get out of
town yeah I'd be like we're going to
leave and never come back ever not even
to visit I found this in your
room is it the necklace
yeah she doesn't remember any of it
that's good honey this is Father Dy hi
Father hello does he possess it
now
what feel like it's in she just
recognized the neck thing and knowing
that the priest helped her when she was
possessed and that's why she yeah I feel
like he possesses it now uh oh because
he was blessing the other guy when he
was dying yeah I thought you'd like to
keep this yeah yeah you're going to need
it why don't you keep
it we going to get the the music the
iconic music from the had your lunch
no hope that house gets
condemned torn
down
yeah oh boy
oh all right
okay yeah I mean all
right that's gonna H hunt you for a good
time yeah I mean it's
just the green the green gak is g to
stick with me yeah like defin oh Max
vono Wonder yeah okay um no I mean I I
definitely get why that's such an iconic
horror film yeah um I don't know I I'm
going to have to have a talk with my
father I don't I mean again 1973 was a
different time period i they're saying
stuff like that maybe in the 70s they
were like we don't say that you know I
know but the whole theater got cleared
up I mean again there were definitely
moments that were frightening for sure
totally I mean I just don't know if I
was the language yeah I just don't know
if I buy the whole them going have to
call my dad out on that we'll have a
talk with him about that but uh talking
about the whole I really I mean it was
definitely a slow burn but you know the
way it was paced and you know the type
of film making they were going for I
actually appreciated uh the way it was
done and I thought that it was I love
the way that they got us so invested in
Reagan and her mother so early on in the
film so that when The Possession did
happen like you really cared for this
character and you wanted you know the
the exorcism to happen so that she was
going to be okay uh rather than her
being an annoying character that you
didn't care for um also too the makeup
in this movie and the special effects
for
1973 fantastically done uh there was a
sense of eeriness uh at all times like
even when a a phone call would would
happen or just like you know sounds of
of like a h whatever it was like I was
always on the edge of my seat I felt
like uh there was a lot of suspense and
tension which I feel like a lot of good
horror films do a good job of doing um
so from perspective I appreciated the
film um and a lot of religious uh
overtones of course um you know about
possession and then just uh and such and
but what did you think of the film I
mean they did a really good job of
setting the foundation with all of the
characters even at the end with the with
the guy that we saw at the very top of
the film going through the artifacts and
he's freaking out with his pills and
then at the end he's in the bathroom
with his pills and we don't even really
know what they are but we do KN know
that it's like linked to that evil I
mean the guy's just like well versed in
evil I like the small things that they
they set up it's not like they had to do
any uh um oh God what do you what's the
word for it uh they didn't do a lot of
uh Exposition I kept wanting to say
exorcism they didn't do a lot of
exposition in regards to like having to
explain certain things like meaning oh
sure they mentioned he wrote a book let
him come do the Exorcist blah blah blah
blah blah a lot of it was mainly just
like where we are right here right now
with mom and daughter and how badly it
started to obviously affect the family
along with obvious the sound design was
insane I mean we never even found out
like why is that noise oh it was just
like the demon in the house the whole
time even before the daughter was like
possessed hearing those sounds up in the
atct there's so many things that were
just set that were scary and weird and
like horror mov esque um and then once
we get off with like uh the the daughter
and getting into uh healing her through
the exorcism I mean that was like we
have we have all been waiting it kind of
was like okay finally now I and I was
very curious to see what would happen I
did not expect the switch at the end I
just thought they were going to be keep
yelling I the Christ the body of Christ
compels you and that it would eventually
go away I yeah I agree with you I I did
not see that all coming as well I just
thought it was going to get out of her
body and that would be it um I thought
the acting was fantastic too from
everyone from the mother uh to the pre
uh I mean I thought the the the priest
too um the one who um uh at the we saw
at the beginning in Iraq and then of
course he was the main priest in
performing uh the exorcism and uh the
PRI the priest that we I can't remember
his name in the film but the priest that
we were focusing on mainly throughout
the fil PR the boxer priest with his
mother uh who unfortunately passed away
in the film and he felt guilty about
that not being there by her side um and
you know I I I felt that guilt I felt
bad for him and just like you know that
that sense of you know where he was
coming from and like you know that he
wanted to really help this this poor
girl and what she was going through and
that he was able to you know he felt so
helpless in that moment with his mother
and that he wanted to do something for
this uh Poor Unfortunate uh girl uh in
terms of what was happening to her and I
I really thought he had a nice Arc um
you know especially at the end where I
again I did not see that coming but I
also I love the I kind of used this word
earlier but I love the intensity that
all the actors brought to their roles um
especially the mother the priest but
that little girl too the daughter that
is not an easy role I think she's messed
up right she had to be messed up from
this role because yeah that's a tough
one I mean to do uh I mean because at
the begin I mean just in the the cutesy
scenes that she was doing at the
beginning she did a great job there but
like the makeup and then having to
pretend like your POS it was that's a
really difficult I mean any acting is
hard in general but for however old she
was in real life that is a very tough
and challenging Ro young yeah and she
did a heck of a job she did a fantastic
job I also wonder if it messed her up
like a little bit cuz the stuff that she
has to go through and say and and act
out and she did a really really great
job uh she did a good job playing
demented just wondering if you were a
little demented after too I'd be curious
to know yeah and also too I as I also
mentioned during the reaction that music
which I had heard from haunted houses
and just I also I listen to Pandora I
know I'm a nerd I listen to movie music
Danny Elfman radio it's really good
listen to it uh I love that iconic music
oh yeah it's so damn good and you
pointed out too the sound design this
movie it's really really good I mean
again it just got me on the edge of my
seat just from telephones ring and
everything like everything is scaring
the crap out of me right now so yeah and
it was it is more just more uh Cinema
forward type of a horror movie where all
of the shots that they're choosing
whether it be like a crane shot from
above bringing us in or even static to
like a dolly shot tracking people as as
they speak they did take a lot of they
took a lot of air lot of space in scenes
that didn't really
necessarily yeah it's a setup but they
don't like really matter like when she's
around with all of the doctors they took
a lot of time just just taking the
reaction of the doctor after the mom
freaked out following him all the way
around until he's like now it's the
reveal of like I think have you heard of
what an exorcism is um I just didn't I
enjoyed that they took their time with
it just with shots like that you
wouldn't get that today or you would but
I think up Abes would be like it's too
long uh or take it out or something and
I really felt for the mother too I can
only imagine like you're going
everywhere psychiatrists doctors it's
like you feel so hopeless in this like
what the hell is this and what the hell
do I do you know type of thing um so
even like the CAT scan and her her
getting like all of her x-ray I mean
even that was like terrifying to watch
oh that's going to stick with me to the
the in the neck the needle in the neck
yeah blood started coming out no thank
you and I was on your side where I'm
like I about put you under please yeah
like put her under I do not mind like a
bat going against a head and it's sweet
sweet revenge and you see blood that the
neck no thank you uh also just like the
green projectile vomit no thanks um I'm
kind of curious what they did use for
that um avocados I swear to God it
literally it looks like it looks like
fresh green avocados mixed with like
green food coloring and like mayonnaise
and no I they didn't use that cuz she
can't keep that in her mouth but I'm
like ah you know what shot freaked me
out the most throughout uh when she was
possessed by the devil the whatever when
she was going down the stairs like oh
God yeah the blood just came out MTH the
blood squ out of the mouth that shot
freaked me out the most of anything that
was probably the most iconic shot to me
and freaked out shot as well I think
that one mixed with her head just it's
coming around we can see it coming no
thank you that's uh yeah I think those
two really like set me off I mean in
general this film is a great is a great
horror film super like Cinema esque uh I
really love the shots obviously they
they they did focus a lot on like the
cinematography which I very much enjoy
which you should in a horror movie but
there's some that they don't really
maybe it's more script forward this one
the shots that they chose even the fog
they put in front of the house when the
E when the uh the priest comes to visit
it like we said that looks like the
poster they always had that fog going in
front of the house setting a a tone even
later in the middle of the movie when we
see the neighborhood for a moment it
went to Blue tone like after she became
possessed I think there was just like
little things like that that they put uh
you know effort and thought into uh that
I think made it just a really Great
Piece of Cinema oh yeah no it's like I
said I I obviously I've never seen the
film but that shot I I know I've seen
that whether it was from the poster just
from a tri something but it was it's
just again iconic that that image it's
definitely that image because I do I've
never seen this before and the image of
the girl with the green eyes I've never
seen that before with her skin all weird
uh and that to me would be like yeah
let's put that on the poster it looks
the most messed up I got to imagine they
at minimum were nominated for uh I I
don't know if in 1973 or 1974 whatever
this uh the nominations could have been
for this film I got to imagine that they
were at least nominated for best uh
special effects and makeup and like the
breath stuff in the cold room and I was
like wait did we have those effects back
in the 70s is just what my brain kept
thinking I was really impressed yeah
yeah because now you don't even have to
second guess it but I'm like obviously
they're not making them work in an
environment that's like very very cold
to where their breast shows it's all
after you know special effect stuff
course um and I just kept thinking did
we have that in the 70s when they made
this movie because it all looks
fantastic uh in the bed move I wonder
how they did that um because it's not
like they would be green screening it
out with someone like lifting the bed
I'm sure they just put it on Hydraulics
and you just you it's clear stuff but uh
I don't think we're like rotoscoping out
in the 70s so all of it nice job for the
70s I don't know what all the special
effects we had back then but great job
no but again really good uh great what
would you I'd probably go in the 8.5 8.8
just going to ask somewhere in that
range yeah I I'll go I'll go uh I'll go
wait I'll go wait man um great film
loved it I feel like now when I see
people walking around I am a huge fan of
Halloween and spooky time so now when I
see people walking around with an
exorcist shirt I can be like I get it I
get it I'm with you I understand it
freaky any last thoughts you can say the
power of Christ compels you oh yeah good
good good maybe I'll just wear that
shirt people will be like Exorcist right
they'll they'll get it it'll be like an
inside thing um that's it that's all I
got I mean this movie kind of messed me
up it kind of made me tired cuz my
adrenaline was so high cuz I was scared
and normally when I watch scary movies
on this channel I'm like tired after I'm
like I don't have all the thoughts right
I'm not being as eloquent and um yeah I
don't have as many words I think my
father hyped this up a little too much
just just a little I was freed in terms
of in terms of the scariness fact it was
a great film I just mean the scariness
Factor hype up but yeah I really enjoyed
it though it's a good film he's got to
go home and call his dad and yell at him
and I have to go take a nap so we love
you guys so much uh don't forget you
know like comment leave us nice things
tell us what we should watch next we
love you all and we'll see you later
goodbye